Riley first of all uh in the order of
business where are you right
now I am in the south island of New
Zealand in a little town called hokka
hokka okay have you heard of that yeah
sure no no one's heard of Hoka Tika it's
a small town uh you're you're in an a
little island uh south of New Zealand
wow in South New Zealand in south south
island of new New Zealand so it's um
yeah it's it's um I was in the North
Island for a while but we moved to the
South Island and it's like a different
country it's absolutely amazing it's you
know giant
mountains um nothing to kill you in the
wild so are you like are you in Hobbit
country it is Hobbit country yeah so
it's it's it's the majority of Lord of
the Rings was filmed in the south island
now I know where you are okay that's I
mean that's extra I know that uh Peter
Jackson shot the movies in New Zealand
but that's incredible Countryside where
you live just beautiful gorgeous it is
so beautiful and I basically live in a
hobbit house I live in a container house
uh which is 40 ft and um I'm quite hay
so you could call me Fro baggin if you
like wait a minute Riley let's back up
the bus just a second you said you live
in a container house what's a container
house so it's a container a 40ft
container like a shipping container
that's been
converted uh very slightly it's quite
rough into a house so we all live in
like one bedroom we poop into a bucket
oh um wait a minute who's we all who's
we all the poop
Club well it's uh myself my beautiful
wife we we married eight years today and
my two I'm not going to celebrate this
marriage until I find out a little more
fair enough fair enough uh let's I'm not
going to yay you're in a shipping
container dude uh now you're in you're
you live in a shipping container that
you say is uh 40
40t 40t by what yeah 40t it's small it's
small and we got four dogs and two
beautiful children six-year-old and a
three-year-old girl they're both girls
and they're my world but no I'm sorry
your world is a shipping container
that's what your world is
I've got a I've got a very I've got a
wife that's real understanding you know
I'm 6'3 280 lb I I can fit in this house
there's a doorway that I'm getting a
little chubby around my tummy at the
moment I used to be a lot more ripped
and then I I can fit in this doorway
just if I move sideways and that gets me
to the toilet so it's the toilet the
toilet is a
bucket it's a beautiful bucket though
you know it's it's it's orange I'm sorry
my favorite color con you sold me yeah
does it flush and have Plumbing or is it
just no okay it doesn't it's a
compostable toilet and every second day
you know we put sawdust once we've done
our business uh then every second day we
take it out into the bush and pour it
into a big area where all our our our
stuff lay and then we can use that as
compost so if you ever come over at
Conan you can eat some of our beautiful
fruit and vegetables that's made from ow
feces um wow maybe the nicest offer I've
had in many a year if you'd like to join
me in my small
box you can eat from our
says Riley every Christmas season
it's the same thing demands for more
podcast episode comes in and we've got
to meet those demands we got to mail out
those podcasts we got to get them in the
mail well guess what with stamps.com all
you need is a computer and printer then
you're ready for that holiday rush you
know what I'm saying remember last year
when we were stuffing podcast into
envelopes and licking them and putting
on the stamps it was crazy in here no
more not with stamps.com they even send
you a free scale so you have everything
you need to get started cuz whenever I
go to mail stuff out I'm like where's my
scale well they got the scale ready
there for you now taking care of orders
on the go is even easier with the
stamps.com mobile app if you need a
package pickup you can easily schedule
it through your stamps.com
dashboard and if you sell products
online stamps.com seamlessly connects
with every major Marketplace and
shopping cart get your business ready
for the holiday Rush get started with
stamps.com today sign up at stamps.com
Conan for a special offer that includes
a four-week trial plus free postage and
a free digital scale no long-term
commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com Conan Riley uh you I'm I'm
sorry it's the bucket I hate to get too
graphic but is the bucket inside the
shipping
container cuz there's no amount of
Sawdust in the world I mean what are you
talking about you're in a small 40ft by
6t trailer and you're pooping into a
bucket yeah it's I'm s now I'm
depressing him I know did you not
realize my life is there a separated
room there is a little room divider for
it is a little room yes um I there is a
little so what we've got is there's a
little so there's a bucket there's a
toilet seat and then there is a ho that
has a fan on it that blows all the bad
air out so it's not that bad um it's not
the worst thing in the world and it's
not having acid put into your empty eye
socket you're right it's not the worst
thing in the world though but it's right
next to it cuz I have a list here of the
worst things in the world and acid in
the eye socket is you're right is one
worse than poop bucket in a container in
a very hot environment uh Riley um and
you say your wife's okay with this life
did you did she accept this life right
away or did it take a while for her to
AC
us she's Scottish so she's very frugal
um so she wants to save money she's used
to living in a shitty
environment everyone in Scotland
immediately say like yeah if it's
between Scotland or a hole I guess
I'll take the hole come on that's
she saves money on saves money on Power
and Water and fertilizer so those three
things are saved so she's very very
happy I mean last time I spoke to her
about it she was happy about it but
eight years marriage you know I must be
doing something right yes I I I don't
mean to um and I'm just going to say
this uh on your life in any way uh
I because you seem like a happy person
and I'm sure it's a nice situation but
um I just think having all these it
sounds like you have a lot of animals
too in addition to children and it's a
very confined space so do you ask do
people take turns using the house and
then other people go
outside it basically we're just a very
close family we stayed in a bigger house
for a a little while and I always
thought we didn't communicate as much as
we did if we're in each other's face now
it's a little bit you know we do have to
rub shoulders with each other quite
regularly but
and and when my daughters grow older you
know when they're only six and three now
when they grow older we might have some
issues but for now oh Riley you are
going to have issues where are they now
I imagine they're just right off screen
yeah I'm I'm actually in my little
camper van outside the front of my house
so it's a little crappy camper van and
um they're inside I I I've banished them
to The Container oh so you're not in the
container right now no no and we also
got a house bus down we've got five
acres is so which is two two and a half
hectares so we got a house bus on the
property that you will stay in when you
come car son and Matt it's beautiful
it's got its own bucket we don't sheare
a bucket so it's got its own bucket oh
so I don't have to bring a bucket I love
that cuz whenever I put my bucket
in the overhead compartment on Delta
they just they they get all in my
face they would excuse me sir I'm like
hey it's my bucket yeah you should
have emptied it first before you tried
to put it in the overhead B I it was
late to get to the flight I didn't want
to miss
it